we have an Emmy Award winner right here
on the set and he is back in the role of
Christine baskets which earned him that
Emmy Award last year a basket season 3
premiered yesterday on FX and airs every
single Tuesday at 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time co-starring with Zach Galifianakis
Louie Anderson here on the show good to
see you so Rachel are you I am doing
better for you being here thanks for
coming out my pleasure I'm thrilled to
be here I I'm a huge sports fan and you
know I'm licking my wounds from the yeah
playoffs you know that Super Bowl is
gonna be in my hometown so close so so
close but I just might rather have what
happened then then at the Super Bowl
interest I do not want that I did not
want that to have so we'd rather give
that up because we've had disappointment
in the Super Bowl
so because we had a poll question here
just last week Louie after your Vikings
did to the Saints what they did to the
Saints and after the Patriots did to the
Titans what they did to the Titans we
asked which way would you rather lose
would you rather lose in the manner that
the Vikings beat the Saints where you
were at into the end and you just get
gutted or would you rather just get
blown out and not even have that sort of
heart a campaign what was there you know
we they do I think everybody chose the
the the awful way out yeah they chose
the other ones like your fault for a
plate it just happened just like it did
with the Saints you get even the the st.
guy I feel sorry for them okay
they gotta live with that until they can
get that right true but the Vikings it
was just like a slow like a we lost the
front line
we lost the flank they took the ship I
we even in this anymore it was awful and
that must be the most disheartening
thing but I get I think that on a team
like that so really young in so many
ways the Vikings yeah with the
quarterback that came in and really made
the year made everybody happy sorted the
year I think that this will be a real
growth thing I never learned anything by
people saying hey hey great show I only
learned when I had a bad
show I think you only learned stuff when
you have a difficulty I think that's
what makes you who you are so where were
you watching the that moment where the
the big Stefan dig 61 yarder from Case
Keenum what happened here's the best
thing I live in Vegas so I went and
visited Marty Allen from Rossi Allen and
Rossi like the old 95 years old get out
here yeah he was ie he's recovering from
a broken hip which at 95 makes sense
right great guy I wouldn't visited him
then I went right back home and I
watched alone oh he has I said I don't
want anyone Jinxy me I don't want anyone
texting me
I don't want anybody bothering me I
missed I just I did and then I went it
of course people you know I just I've
because when something like that happens
now you want to share it right now you
want to make sure that he will go out
now tell her I'll call everybody I do
all that south but if you lose you just
I just crawled into the bathtub like
there was a storm coming and just late
no I'm just it's hard you know because
Vikings you know you know don't always
get any national respect I don't know if
you notice that but they're not
mentioned you know oh yeah my keys are
this too by the way in case you're
wondering yeah you know what I mean
exact like they were starting to get
some and they certainly play great
defense hey here's what happens
you're either prepared for something mmm
or it over won't you I think that's true
in life I remember my second Tonight
Show I thought it would go as good as
the first Tonight Show but I didn't
count the adrenaline and everything the
second one I go oh my god even though it
was good they loved it
I felt like oh I don't I don't think I I
was prepared for that now Johnny Carson
personally invited you to come on or if
so he saw you or what happens is there's
talent coordinators look there must be
people who bring you guests and you go
no and no I said no to that guy and
forget it yeah no but I mean and then
you have people who go out they see the
comedian's in the clubs and this and
that's what happened with me and you
know I auditioned several times I've
they got on there was a life goal of
mine a dream come true and it was from
Minnesota out there that's right from
the projects in Minnesota so I was
really like I felt really like I scored
so you grew up in the projects of
Medicine the projects in the Minnesota
which are a little different than
everywhere else we have lawns people
shoveled there walks you know I mean
sure I mean it really was you know
different it was like I mean you know
there was troubles but it wasn't sure it
wasn't like it wasn't deigned it didn't
feel dangerously mean there sure I want
to take it up with my dad except with
your dad well I mean you were one of
eleven kids right I was and now I was
tenth of eleven and now you're playing
your mom essentially on television I
know whatever what a wittmeyer knee-high
an Emmy Award for two I want to take a
60-second break come back talked a
little bit about that and then some you
know Jack Morris is going in the Hall of
Fame yeah and we've we do have we do
have a contest where we're coming up
with what's the greatest Minnesota icon
ever who is the greatest I got it well
it's sort of mine it's sort of law you
got yours I'm sure off the top you read
but I want you to help us work through
our bracket yeah that we've got going on
all right you know I'm not I'm you know
there are other people who are more but
I ain't no I'm pretty no no no you wait
see here the the okay wait to hear the
matchups all right okay that's next in
60 seconds with Louie Anderson here on
the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
welcome back to the show the 60 seconds
you are gone Louie Anderson made a joke
about AT&T right AT&T you know like home
here yeah it's beautiful in here
love them I have AT&T since the very
early mid data the old it is but I can't
use it up I got nothing to do I can only
take so many selfies well maybe well
maybe you you're downloading all the
videos of draymond Green who use
yourself please I mean I love Steve Kerr
and the Warriors are great but I'm
Minnesota Timberwolves fans you're gonna
be fired up about what's going on I love
it and and you know as long as Tibbs
doesn't kill all the players you know he
reminds me of my gym teacher take
another lap Anderson let's go gym
teacher used to torture me I go why am I
taking another lap one lap should count
as three laps when you're fat gosh coach
Tibbs is a taskmaster he is I mean I
always felt like I shouldn't say this
but I did eat was he the person who you
know Derrick Rose it was just too much
for him Keyes how many you only have so
many jumps you only have so many run I
think this I mean you know look at all
the great players you only have so many
and once they're out you know father
time catches up you're done for there is
no unlimited plan there's a TNT I'm just
a homer man I'm just a you see games in
the old Metrodome okay yes old twins
games like the old twins games the
Humpty dome we called it hung hubert
humphrey Metrodome sure I saw the last
game there okay yeah the last game with
I was in you know and I that's the
greatest thing about being it was a
little successful i sat in with the twin
Smalley Hrbek all those guys then I went
in the boxes Rod Carew Tony Oliva Harmon
kill I got pictures with all those guys
these are people my dad and I you know
we didn't do much but we did watch twins
base
hmm and so it's really a thrill for me
and Harmon and Smalley you know I've
been it did a benefit and the Harmon
became someone I talked to a lot you
know he's a friend and I loved Harmon
and he did it he does a beautiful thing
his organization mm-hmm he builds rubber
ball field for kids with disabilities so
they can run and play and not get hurt
did not know that I mean this is a this
guy you know one of the greatest hitters
of all time yeah so is Carew to her oh
and they like I have that picture -
these are big things for me there's a
Karen st. Paul it's for everybody and
things for everybody I do believe that
is the first mention in the three and a
half year or almost four years in stirry
the show of Roy Smalley I've not heard
that you know Roy Smalley gets he's a
great play I mean yeah I mean I just I I
really enjoyed I have to be honestly
there during this series I happened to
go to you know one of the games because
of how great FX says I got to go to one
of the playoff and one of the World
Series and I loved the stuff they were
doing you know with all the play-by-play
in all the different places I enjoyed it
I love seeing those players I loved
seeing the real you know I'd like when
they can just let not worry about their
legacy and just say what they really
mean
we'll talk baskets in a second here with
Louie Anderson again Emmy Award winner
twice a Daytime Emmy Award winner for
for your for your show life with Louie
from which was which was great and I do
want to ask you about a couple of movies
that you were in way back in the sheriff
you were you're in Ferris Bueller's Day
as the flower delivery guy John Hughes
was a fan of mine so he just plucked a
little piece and gave it to me as a part
I was a very good actor at that time but
you know now I feel like I've come into
my own so but I had a lot of fun doing
that I I loved it I you know I I was a
good actor but I get nervous in the
auditions you would yeah okay cuz I'm a
comic you know I depend on jokes and
yeah I used to get nervous in the
auditions well you passed the audition
for coming to America working at
McDowell's
as well what was it like being on the
set of that movie
that was so much fun you know john
landis you know one of the best comedy
directors of all time Eddie Murphy one
of the greatest comedians and actors of
all time Arsenio Hall that's right you
know
Arsenio was there all the stars are Amos
John Amos McDowell himself yes
Darth Vader was in there played the
father you know the father of the whole
yeah James Bulger and then now what's
his name who robbed me samuel l.jackson
he Rob's me and that was a great scene
and you know that that movie got you
know like I that was a such an iconic
movie and you know I heard I can't say
who told me but that the second ones
that definitely gonna happen no kidding
yeah coming to America too yeah I hope I
still have the same job that's what I
was to me that would be the funny part
I mean maybe assistant manager at least
maybe but it would be really funny if I
was still so gung-ho Jackson's Robin you
know she should be working next to these
would-be workshopping it yeah so let's
talk baskets here what a fun show and
you were awesome anything are you
playing your mom essentially I'm playing
a combination of five sisters my mom and
every probably mom I ever met in Midwest
and and throughout my life my mom was a
I have a book coming out called hey mom
hmm
you can go to Louie book calm and find
out all about it get a special advance
copy but autographed and but my mom
raised 11 children and my dad was an
alcoholic so she's defiantly stood in
between him and us so that we were
protected and she was just an awesome
person and so funny and lots of things
and so I kind of steal some of her looks
nuances but Jonathan kreisel and Zach
Galifianakis
they helped guide me into this part you
know Jonathan kreisel from
and many many other things and so this
has been like such a great growth thing
for me and such a great experience it's
gonna ask you when you when your pitch
to say okay we'd like you to play a
woman yeah that just and it's not it's
not a transgender or somebody's
transitioning your flag you're just
you're playing a woman well you know I
was doing my mom in my act for years
sure I would do the voice and when they
said would you do a character I said
yeah and then they said would you play
Zach's mom and I go yes finally yeah I
mean because it's so much fun to have a
challenge like that
but you know what the greatest thing is
is that I I think I just play it as a
really human a real human being for me
that's the best part I don't try to
cartoon it up I I'm playing a real I
play I act like I'm their mother and I
and I believe in the when I'm there I
play that character to the fullest
well it's hilarious and it's it's it's
human and they don't just hand out Emmy
Awards for nothing so congratulations on
that thank you I saw yours in the
dressing room well that's from 1996
doesn't man nobody says this is from
1990 when I was one of 40 Sports Center
anchors oh listen I don't care what they
say you you have your show they don't so
haha scoreboard is that what you said I
should just point us to city or go I
would have the Emmy here holding up some
yeah all right one specifically for the
show do you get one you deserve then we
will create a new leg people like me on
you'd probably get one well let you go
speaking of baskets in a way so normally
this is associated with NCAA basketball
tournament action other bracket we have
created a bracket seeded people one
through sixteen for the greatest
Minnesota icon ever in advance of us
going to Minneapolis last week let's
hear it yeah so we have in today's go
Golden Gopher region okay okay I'd like
to help you you have we're gonna unveil
this for the first time and you can vote
get on this Louie Anderson the third
seed is Jack Morris no against the 14
seed f scott Fitzgerald you're doing I
like what you're doing is we're
driven by the place he lived many a time
growing as you know he's in an all-time
grand Minnesotan and like Jack Morris he
got stronger as the rioting grew longer
as well you know what I mean so who
would you who would you choose to
advance than the three and 14 seed Louie
Anderson Jack Morris I mean I love scott
Fitzgerald but he's he never really
played okay so the Great Gatsby is out
Jack Mars is through to the were at
second round and then in the six eleven
game the sixth seeded Paul Molitor
against the 11th C to Jessica Lange oh
well it's not just it this is just we're
not saying this is a it's gotta be like
one-on-one like if ma if MA if she threw
a pitch to Molitor what do you rake it
down the right-field line it's just in
general like all right all right
I mean she's won Oscars Emmys I got a
Tony I gotta go with Jessica Lange
lowness Jessica Lange with the first
upset of the tournament so far so you're
gonna post this on our Twitter feed
right posting it right now okay so Jack
beats F scott Fitzgerald yeah I mean you
know just for me because mm-hmm you know
I just think I mean yeah I gotta go
there and and when we don't you know
Jessica such an icon she is still
working and I love all that stuff isn't
she on an FX show too
yeah see that's it's synergy she's on
the feud and it's synergy it's great in
the future really great answers are on
the board here's your question
great to see you Louie thank you thanks
for coming on here at Louie Anderson on
Twitter check out baskets every single
Tuesday at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience